Ist sie im bereich der nasa eine
sensation die eine revolution in der raumfahrt möglich macht konkret werden
mikrowellen dabei in einem gegen förmigen wohnraum aus kupfer hin und her bewegt so soll ein schub erzeugt werden quasi ein
treibstoff loser antrieb der nur mit sonnenenergie
funktionieren würde der nicht nur eine kolonie auf dem mars sondern auch die erkundung des äußeren
sonnensystems leichter machen könnte und jetzt gibt es eine neue studie dazu klick zum zweiten fiction herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für den themenvorschlag
auf whatsapp dort in der community
Das große problem der raumfahrt und der erkundung des weltalls ist einfach seine gigantische größe die distanzen zwischen den zahlreichen
himmelskörpern sind einfach enorm für uns menschen sind sie ohne warp antrieb mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit
kaum zu schaffen
jedenfalls nicht in zeiträumen die wir uns erträumen die anderen systeme die wir bislang kennen brauchen viel zu viel treibstoff
das alles stellt uns vor in bezug auf unsere vision ja vor riesige
logistische probleme zu schön um wahr zu sein erschien dann im jahr 2014 die idee der nasa ein neuartiges
antriebssystem das kein treibstoff braucht nach bestimmten quanten prinzipien funktioniert und das obwohl es die
bekannten grund gesetze der physik verletzt ein
science fiction antrieb der vielleicht alle unsere raumfahrt visionen wahr machen könnte
doch schon damals war trotz aller euphorie
klar die nasa hatte keinesfalls einen solchen neuen antrieb realisiert einen
prototypen oder gar ein neues raumschiff
gebaut der kurze bericht der veröffentlicht wurde bezog sich auf das sogenannte e m drive konzept des britischen ingenieurs roger gioia
der hatte ein gerät entwickelt das eine antriebskraft ohne treibstoff erzeugen kann und dass nur durch die reflektion von
mikrowellen in einem kegel hohlraum demnach würden sich
wechselwirkungen mit teilchen und quantenfluktuationen
ergeben die diese kraft erzeugen doch das arbeit wurde hart kritisiert beispielsweise
für einige enthaltene fehler die er abstritt aber auch dafür dass er seine ergebnisse nicht in einer wissenschaftlichen zeitschrift
veröffentlicht hatte die nachdem peer review verfahren
arbeitet also wo wissenschaftler vor der veröffentlichung
die eingereichten studien
überprüfen ja doch dagegen standen wiederum die experimente eines chinesischen
forschungsteams das tatsächlich solch eine antriebskraft gemessen haben wollte auch das entsprechende
nasa team um herald weit hatte bei ihren untersuchungen einen solchen effekt
aufgespürt auch wenn dieser etwas kleiner war als der den ihre chinesischen kolleginnen und kollegen gefunden hatten
in ihrem wirklich ziemlich kurzen bericht schreibt die nasa von verschiedenen tests durchgeführt wurden um klarzustellen dass
das messeergebnis nicht von einem anderen effekt hervorrufen oder
beeinflusst worden war zitat test results
indicate that the president quit procter design ist für jüdische volk das is not a tribute to any klassiker
elektromagnetik phänomenta defoe ist potenziell
demonstrierten interaction with it quantum ray
cambridge usa die gemessene kraft seit demnach also nicht durch klassische magnetische phänomene zu erklären
stattdessen sei möglicherweise eine interaktion mit virtuellem quanten plasma anzunehmen in dem kurzen bericht von
2014 ist also wirklich nur von den messungen die rede und das nasa forschungsteam gab zu diesem reinen
laborexperiment keine physikalische begründung oder
erklärungen ab der arbeit zufolge jedenfalls könnte der m3 für einen treibstoff losen antrieb sorgen den benötigten strom für die
mikrowellen könnte man im weltraum beispielsweise durch solarenergie gewinnen und ihre reflexion
sorge dann für den schub doch die kritik an dem experiment riss nicht ab
schließlich war der gemessen effekt sehr sehr klein und die meisten forscherinnen und forscher weltweit glaubt er an einen messfehler
als an eine sensation und genau das konnte etwa zwei jahre später überprüft werden denn die ergebnisse von
nasa-forscher white und den kolleginnen und kollegen
wurden dann offiziell in einer fachzeitschrift veröffentlicht die wissenschafts community begann mit der qualitätskontrolle
und im mai 2018 kam dann eine große studie der universität dresden heraus sie hatte man sich jahrelang mit der
mysteriöse schubkraft beschäftigt und den ganzen versuch unter anderem auch in einer vakuumkammer
laufen lassen so sollte man alle äußeren einflüsse ausschließen zudem wurden die meisten vorgänge
automatisiert und mit einer extrem genauen fusions waage auch die kleinsten schubkräfte
messbar gemacht und tatsächlich am anfang stimmte die datenlage mit den messergebnissen
der
nasa über ein durch die reflektion der mikrowellen entsteht im kegel inneren eine kleine schubkraft so schien es doch jetzt haltet euch fest
diese konnte das forschungsteam auch messen wenn gar kein schuh
produziert wurde heißt also ganz konkret selbst wenn keine mikrowellen im kegel vorhanden waren ließ sich diese kraft messen das fazit des dresdener
forschungsteams ist deswegen eindeutig der effekt entsteht nicht durch irgendwelche
mysteriösen wechselwirkungen zwischen dem quanten vakuum und den mikrowellen sondern lässt sich auf eine ganz andere
wechselwirkung zurückführen nämlich auf die uns bekannte wechselwirkung zwischen dem erdmagnetfeld
und den stromführenden
kabeln des em drives und ihr könnt euch vorstellen auch dieses
experiment wird nicht von allen gefeiert und na klar ein perfektes
experiment gibt es nicht und vielleicht lässt sich auch an der aktuellen studie etwas finden was
theoretisch noch retten könnte
ja wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er hier die kaputte abo
box auf youtube und verpasst kein video mehr denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwestern anna klicks um social and media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
schwimmer die glocke vergessen und dir geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken neuer
revolutionärer raumfahrt am trieb bis dann
bleibt an